[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrass
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this is a cosmic
queries
star talk all about a.i
and the ethics of a.i and what it means
and
what are robots and their relationship
with us and our relationship with
animals and what does all that mean
and how and why are we all gonna die
okay
negan you're gonna help me help us
figure this one out
oh my first of all i'm glad that you
started with are we all gonna die
because that's the first question on
everybody's mind
like let's just lay it out that's why
we're all tuning in today neil
thank you thank you negem for assad that
this is
your your your i ca i've lost count of
how many times you've been my co-host
and it's a delight to have you back and
again you're the host of the podcast
fake the nation which i i was delighted
to have been
one of your guests but apparently only
once that
invitation never came back i don't know
talk about that later you gotta earn
[Laughter]
uh you're also a voice of someone on a
new animated adult
swim cartoon what's the what's the name
of that
it's called bird girl and it's really
fun
and really ridiculous i
i'm not bird girl i am meredith the mind
taker
uh so i go into people's minds
and i i can tell what they're doing and
then i can also change their minds
so i feel like uh it's a superpower that
i
use sparingly um but i do use it neil so
be careful
crazy and one of my favorite things
you've done is your book
how to make white people laugh did i get
that title right
oh yeah
and you get to say that because you're
like you're from the middle east or
something so you're allowed to
yeah light-skinned people
iranian-american muslims you know we get
to say stuff like that sometimes
you know what i mean yeah so i i
while i read a lot about ai i claim no
particular
expertise for that we had to go to the
source
so up to cambridge massachusetts and the
one and only kate darling kate welcome
back to star talk
thanks for having me again yeah you're
an expert in
robot ethics that's just a crazy thing
that
like i don't want to have to think about
that but you know we have to think about
that
right and you know human robot
interactions
uh tech policy of course policy is
influenced by this
um and you have a doctor of scientists
from the swiss
federal institute of technology did i
get that right yep that's correct
and i don't i'm afraid i'm going to ask
you about this i'm just going to read it
and we'll move on
your caretaker of several domestic
robots
let's move on i don't want to know i
don't know anyone know what that means
your latest book came about in april
2021
the new breed what our history with
animals
reveals about our future with robots
and this is a cosmic queries and so our
whole fan base
is like ready they're like at the gates
at the start of the race trying to
understand
what all this is about but i want to
just lead off with a few questions
what would you say was our single
biggest
ethical challenge with regard to robots
other than
they'll kill us all oh it's interesting
because i actually wrote the book
because
i don't think the question whether they
will kill us all
is the single biggest ethical challenge
even though it's really oh there's a
there's a bigger challenge than that oh
oh
oh negine what what
the bigger challenge is like will they
kill us all but be really nice while
they're doing it
is that challenge
they'll be nice on the right
side of the plate in the process
of kelly like what's their etiquette
skill yeah there you go
yeah that you know i never thought about
that one but that might be the single
biggest question um you know will they
will they have good table manners no no
i think i think that there are a lot of
ethical questions actually and we're at
a very unique moment in time because
robots have been around for many decades
but they've been kind of behind the
scenes in factories and behind
walls and in cages and now they're
coming into shared spaces
and we're kind of trying to figure out
how to live with them and what they can
be used for and
um one of the things that i try to do
with the book
is move away from this constant
comparison we have of robots to humans
and artificial intelligence to human
intelligence and these narratives we
have about them taking over
and replacing us and i tried to push a
different analogy which is animals
and i look at the ways that we've
harnessed animals for work
for weaponry for companionship for
millennia
and how we've partnered with animals not
because they do what we do but because
their skill sets are so different from
ours and so as we move into the future
of artificial intelligence and robotics
we should be thinking of these
technologies as a partner in what we're
trying to achieve
and if we can do that and get rid of
some of the moral panic that we have
then we can start addressing some of the
actual issues that i think are at play
that often have to do much less with the
technology
than they have to do with humans making
choices against the backdrop of
corporate capitalism or oppressive
governments uh
and so it's really all up to us at the
in the end
and not up to the robots to determine
the future okay
i have to push back i have to push with
your permission
may i push back please okay so
uh when we harness oxen
to pull the plow and horses to do
other kinds of farming and we have dogs
that sniff out
whatever so we are using certain talents
that each of these
creatures possess at no time
are we relying on
any animal's intelligence really not not
in the way we think of intelligence all
right i don't go to my dog say i'm
having problems with this calculus
question
can you help me out here no okay okay
stop licking your butt and help me out
you know this is
i'm just saying so hold on neil i take
offense on behalf of my pomeranian who
does
excellent calculus theorems
so so oh it's a pomeranian so what
even if it gets the wrong answer it'll
do it cutely right
yeah and shed a lot of fur while he's
doing it it's fantastic
so whereas ai in our dreams
is smarter than us so to say let's
partner with something smarter than us
feels scary and i'm thinking they'll
just really
rather make us their pets and that's the
animal robot
analogy that you should be exploring
what kind of pets
would humans make for the robot
see i feel like that's been explored a
lot and i feel like that
vision of the future relies on a very
narrow
definition of intelligence and is kind
of caught up in this idea that
the artificial intelligence we're
creating is like us but smarter
it's only a matter of time before it is
smarter than us and can outsmart us
um i i don't think that's how
it works and i don't think that's how
it's currently happening and that's not
the trajectory we're on because we
already have machines that are much
smarter than us
we have machines that can do calculus we
have machines that can
beat us at chess and go into jeopardy
and do endless calculations and see
patterns and data
uh they're way better than us at so many
things and then there are
many other areas where we are still much
much much smarter than the machines
it used to be that if you asked apple's
voice assistant to um
siri to call you an ambulance she would
say
okay from now on i will call you an
ambulance because
she didn't understand the context and
apple probably had to fix that by hand
because machines don't perceive the
world or learn about the world or
understand the world the way humans do
uh but even if we could recreate our own
intelligence
and and go along that path of making it
better and better
i just don't think that that's a very
interesting path to
pursue because rather than recreate what
we already have
why aren't we trying to create something
different that we can benefit from
so you say that we haven't uh used
animal intelligence
i don't think that's true that's only
true if you view intelligence
as human intelligence because animals
clearly have a very different skill set
a different
type of intelligence than humans do but
they can perceive the world through
their senses in ways that we cannot
and that has been really useful to us
for a long time
and so we've partnered with them and
we've used them to
supplement our own ability rather than
uh
partnering with them because they
because they can you know do calculus
and also the point of the book is not to
say that animals and robots are the same
or that we should treat them exactly the
same obviously they have very different
skill sets as well
but i'm just trying to open up our minds
to more
opportunities and more possibilities
than just recreating what we already
have
so negan i think the uh
the robots at the mit lab created
kate darling and made her say exactly
this
wait exactly what the robots want us to
think about the robot
yeah who is controlling who kate darling
the other thing i want to point out is
that
kate darling you have the perfect name
for a character in a movie in which
the robots become self-aware and take
over
and you're like you're like the expert
in the background who's like i've been
warning you guys
all along or whatever
the robots were really if they were
really smarter than us they would have
come up with a
less uh you know provocative name though
right
that's true so so nagin give some
questions from i haven't seen these i
don't think kate has either
right i have not these are
all patreon members that we change that
rule now in order to ask a question you
have to be a member
and that just keeps the the wheels
turning of our entire operation so i
just want to publicly thank
patreon members for for this and here's
your reward all right negine give it to
us
okay here we go our first question comes
from patron sean grossman
who asks should who asks could robots
build a habitat for humans on mars
could robots build a telescope on the
moon what are the physical challenges of
building a robot that can operate in
space
it kind of bridges the neil kate darling
divide right there with that question
and we can tag team on this one so kate
why don't you begin
i mean doesn't and what a perfect
example
for something that we should be using
robots for
right anything that's difficult for us
to do
like head to mars and hang out and build
a habitat
we absolutely need machines that can go
to these places where
we currently can't and do work for us so
that's a great use case of supplemental
technology
uh in line with how we used to use
animals to help us do things
so um but in terms of the difficulty
and i'm sure neil will have a lot to say
about this as well
it is very very difficult to create
robots straight up and then to
create robots that can go to space um
i am just in awe every day of
uh nasa and and you know people who have
built
robots that can actually um uh
not only function in space but also i
i mean they have to get everything so
exact and it has to be so precise and
nothing can go wrong and uh
you know even working at mit
uh i see many many things go wrong all
the time with the technology in the labs
so it's very impressive
what we've been able to do and um there
are there are many challenges with it i
don't i don't even know where to begin
um it's a very challenging job something
i've thought about a lot is
i kept thinking when robots take over
and
they will only keep two kinds of humans
the stand-up comedians because robots
don't know how to do that
and i think construction workers because
i
i can't picture construction workers
being replaced by robots
because they're doing such different
things or carrying
things they're they're making decisions
on the spot
and i'm just curious
so so i would wonder how soon if ever
we're going to send robots to mars and
have the robots build something i guess
that's what i'm
trying to think of here yeah i think
that's right robots can help
build something they can they're usually
good at helping people do their jobs but
they're not
great at straight up replacing uh human
workers so
uh it'll yeah it'll probably be a while
before we can have robots just
autonomously do something i mean we
don't even
have automated car factories yet elon
musk tried to automate his tesla factory
and even in a space where everything's
very predictable
and you would think we could have robots
just do the assembly line
he ended up tweeting that humans are
underrated because there's
always something that can go wrong a
screw can fall on the floor
something can happen and robots don't
know how to deal with that you need a
human
and so i think it's more than just
construction workers i think they're
going to need
quite a few humans around for quite a
while and
i don't even think that the robots would
want to
get rid of us because we again have
skill sets that are so different from
theirs
that they would probably want to keep us
all around and i think they want to keep
nadine
right i think they want to keep it i
hope so
the king has the court jester you know
right exactly they need to have some
form of entertainment
exactly um i have a follow-up on the
robots as construction workers which is
that
if robots did become construction
workers would they also still cat call
female passers
it's not just built into the job only
during the lunch break right is that
what they do
yeah that's you know that's how science
fiction movies would
like for example in the jetsons you know
the maid who's a robot
was actually female but it's a but it's
a robot right so
you know it was hard to break out of
these gender stereotypes
that people were you know the the maid
didn't have to have any gender at all
but it was a female
right if it was a wheel then it was
quite the thing so i talked about that
in the book too about how the design of
these robots
a lot of our own biases flow into that
so you know
if if you had construction workers build
a robot a construction working robot
and they like to catcall they might make
the robot
cat call as well i mean we we do this
constantly in like
less funny ways yeah because it's just
if we program it it's got us in it
whether we want it to or not
that's right we think about it even when
we think it doesn't it
does that's the that's the the more
pernicious biases that
uh filter in to what it is we do let's
go for another question in the game
okay carrie manaberg asks we know how to
model cognitive intelligence and
probably even
emotional behavior in machines how close
are we to building machines that can
find an appropriate mate
and then produce offspring and then
teach the offspring behaviors
that are not encoded in the algorithms
uh i love this question because i also
envision a world where there's like
robot tinder you know what i mean
hey is that happening what let's hold on
to that let's take a break
and when we come back we'll return to
this subject of robot tinder
i'll start talk with kate darling we'll
see in a moment
we're back star talk talking about ai
ethics
cake darling has a new book out
comparing our relationship with animals
and what
how that might give us insight to the
future of our relationship with robots
it's been out for several months and
check it out she's at the center
of all we need to be thinking about with
regard to
robot ethics and we're all going to die
i have to end every comment with that
that way
so so nagin you you left off with a a a
fun
question just tell us what that question
is again yeah
well the question is about um you know
we know how to model cognitive
intelligence and probably in bit
and probably even emotional behavior in
machines how close are we building
machines that can find an appropriate
mate
and then produce offspring and then
teach the off-screen behaviors that are
not encoded
in the algorithm
okay why would we do this i mean
there's always this like technological
determinism that because we can do
something we should do something
or that it will happen i um i think that
we
have this total fascination with
recreating ourselves
i think that for art and entertainment
purposes we will always be
chasing these particular goals i don't
think we're as close to modeling
all of human um cognition and
emotional behavior as uh as some people
may think we are
i actually think we're quite a ways away
and i don't really
i i don't really see the purpose of
creating
a robot tinder as the king said
other than that that would be hilarious
and i would love to
swipe through that um which is reason
alone if you ask
me but continue i mean that's fair you
know and
and in that sense you know maybe maybe
it will happen soon
actually i might go back to the lab and
suggest that we create a robot tinder
just because i really want to see that
now
but the flip side of that or an
additional element of that question was
if robots are programmed to have certain
pins or whatever or they can maybe learn
emotions
would a hybrid of those two robots
have to be derivative of what those two
robots were or
can what emerges from it
acquire or self-program a brand new
behavior
that was not seen and what made it i
don't see any reason why we couldn't
at some point do something along the
line
along those lines i i don't think that
anything that
is encoded in us is not
in some way that we couldn't somehow
recreate it
um so in theory i agree that that's
possible
i just don't see it happening anytime
soon um kind of a a
crotchety skeptic in that sense uh
and i think there are plenty of uh other
questions that we need to be
uh focused on right now before we even
get to that one but i do love like the
theoretical question of
what what could that look like um and
i i do i am open to us getting there
all right all right again keep it coming
and i do think like just as someone
i'm the dog i am my mom is in real
estate and my dad's a surgeon and then
together
they made a comedian
yeah i see a future where robots will
come up with a third crazy thing we
didn't even anticipate
there you go there you go all right you
got another one negan
yes from dean clunk we have the question
since we have a sort of narrow idea of
what intelligence and knowledge is
due to humans only seeing humans as such
do you think an
alternate outcome of the evolvement of
robotics and ai
is possible where we don't necessarily
make them leaps and bounds
smarter than us but them becoming
intelligent in ways
we can't even foresee or understand
given our current standings
understandings yes so this is what my
book is
all about that that is actually the
ideal future
we don't want to recreate human
intelligence we do want to recreate
we do want to create something new and
something different something
supplemental
um the one uh thing that i would
add though to that question is that uh
it
we have a lot of agency in this we as
humans can decide
what technology we create uh right so
it's not just
you know is something going to happen or
is something possible it depends
it depends on whether we read my book
and agree
that this is a direction we should go in
or
whether people just buy it and throw it
out i i don't know
uh i i think that we have so much agency
and choice in shaping the future
it's not it's not up to the machines
so that's that's a that's a that's a
warning shot really what you're saying
is
you are offering a path to the future
where we don't all die but that it
becomes a sensible
invocation of of robot technologies and
robot intelligence and
if we don't read your book it's the end
of civilization this is what i got
from you yes because let me be clear we
could all die
[Laughter]
it would be the robot's fault it would
be your fault for not reading my book
no i love it i love it that's the answer
there it is all right nick give me some
more
okay hyperactive jedi says
i'm curious to know how far robots will
get and i'm so sorry kate but this is
we're back to
we're all gonna die okay how far will
robots get with warfare and how would
long-term use of robots such as drones
or even a robot that wipes your
butt due to the psychological standing
of a person controlling slash
using such machines
wait i i kind of wait you lost me at the
wiping the butt part like how did that
connect to
let me lead off here and say yeah please
the original star trek
okay from 1966 67 there was an episode
where a civilization got so advanced
that they conducted warfare
via computer and the computer would log
losses on one side or the other
and all the people who were killed in
that war game
would then have to go into this chamber
and be destroyed
and that's how they were fighting war
the war reached a level where it was
just that organized
and and of course the star trek crew
they're not supposed to interfere with
it but of course they do every single
episode
and they say no you have to know that
war
is hell and war is bloodshed and war is
pain
and war is not just this this this
uh this machine you walk into and just
disappear
because the computer told you to so so
the
the the the the the death and bloodshed
that comes with war seems to be an
important
force in making sure we don't fight wars
in the future
has that really prevented us from
fighting wars because it feels a lot of
them
no but it maybe you'll think twice i
don't i don't know
so so getting back to the question and
then landing in your lap
is there um if we get
better and better at having machines
wage our war what is what is a drone uh
a drone that fires missiles while
someone is with a joystick
two thousand miles away all right
there's
that person doesn't hear or feel the
bloodshed
wrought by the drone and the drone is a
computer
it's a robot so where do you think
this goes kate yeah i mean this is
actually a really important question
because you know the use of
technology and warfare is really
changing the nature of it
um i will point out that we did try to
use animals as autonomous weapons for
for many many years back to ancient
times
which is like an equally kind of setting
an autonomous
technology loose like a flaming pig
in order to wreak havoc and destruction
but
obviously with the machines today we can
do much different things and more
precise things
and it is in in some cases helping
soldiers stay out of the battlefield and
be out of harm's way
but it's also allowing us to make kill
decisions
uh without the same cost of needing to
put people in danger
so um there is a lot of debate over
to what extent we should be allowing um
weapon systems that are autonomous or
semi-autonomous
on battlefields and uh there there's
even
movements to ban autonomous weapon
systems uh before the u.n
um and it's you know i
i think that the direction that this
goes in ultimately depends on
you know where we wanted to go right i
think we should be having these
conversations
i think these are these are the the very
important conversations to be having
rather than
you know are the robots going to come
and kill us all no
like which countries are going to use
robots in which way
to harm people um and to what extent
does removing people from
the battlefield actually lead to more
harm because you don't have that
as much of a cost um to the
the people making the decisions forgive
me for not remembering who said this but
the first time someone was able to kill
another person at a distance
i don't remember if it was a bow and
arrow or some some
military advance where you they're not
right in front of you to kill them they
the person commented
this is the end of valor
right interesting are you are you brave
by launching a missile over a wall
where's where is the bravery in that
where is the valor in that where is the
the
the heroism in that so
yeah or put another way where's the
responsibility in that like
do you feel as responsible for the harm
that you've caused
if you just press the button and it
happened that's
way better put than i just said exactly
can i also i don't want us to forget
about the other really important threat
in this question which is the
psychological impact of a robot
wiping your butt
um
the japanese toilets do they already
wipe your butt
they do they rinse them off and
everything
and some people prefer that because if
you can't wipe your own butt
and you can choose to have you know a
person do it or a robot some people
would choose a robot
i'm hoping everyone would choose the
rope
i'm going to say most that's just me are
going to go robot on that one i'm butt
wiping in particular
i don't know it depends on how often
they go haywire and wreak havoc
i don't yeah right all right
all right time for a couple more before
the end of this segment and again
yes let's see violetta and mom and izzy
ask the following question
i'm going out for my junior high's
archery team this coming school year so
my question is inspired by that and the
robotic
and the robotic bow and arrow seen in
the hunger games
will there be robotic or a.i weaponry in
the future and how will it be used
so a little of a sister question to the
earlier one
yeah i have bad news for you uh we
already have
we don't have the that uh i i don't
believe we have the bow and arrow i'd
have to
i read the hunger games but didn't watch
the movies so i'm not sure
and i don't really remember um but we
already have
robots that can for example aim
and shoot a weapon although uh currently
you know people aren't allowed to let
them just do this autonomously there
always has to be a human in the loop
making a decision we already have robots
that
could do it um and so the question isn't
when will we have those or
are will we the question is what are we
going to do with them
which has been your mantra the whole
time here yes
never the robot's fault is your quality
someone made that robot yeah yeah all
right
all right nagin coming we have pat elvin
uh comes in with a question as machines
become more sophisticated will they
become self-aware and here's the key
how do we protect protect them from
abuse
which sounds like how do we protect the
robots from abuse
like other than how do we protect humans
from robot abuse anyways but both of
those questions
yeah and i want to like put extra
emphasis on the question
achieve self-awareness consciousness i
mean that's
this seems to be the big turning point
in all plot lines
you know when did skynet achieve
consciousness and then you had
terminator
right so can you comment because you
haven't yet
on achieving consciousness and
self-awareness
yes so this is like you said the big
plot line the thing that we're very
interested in about
robots and ai in all of science fiction
what happens when they become conscious
and self-aware
and one of the things that i look at
i just realized we're out of time
no just for this segment
when we come back to star talk our third
and final segment
we'll find out from kate darling what
happens when robots
achieve consciousness on star talk
we're back star talk we're talking about
a.i we got kate darling
not her first rodeo with us because we
this is a topic that comes up
all the time and i got nagin forza nagin
what's your social media handle oh at
nagina farsad on all of the socials
including
a newly uh entered the world of
tick-tock
oh welcome to tick-tock welcome and
again
n-e-g-i-n and f-a-r-s-a-d
yes on all platforms how about you kate
are you you're socially active
i am uh mostly on twitter g-r-o-k
underscore what
[Laughter]
broadcast the character is
[Laughter]
i don't even know who's on here right
now she calls herself
kate all right so okay we were trying to
find out from you
uh from a question uh what what happens
when the robots achieve consciousness
and
how has it already happened and if it
hasn't how
how soon will it happen and if it does
happen is it
is that a watershed moment in
civilization
that's it's such a great question uh
according to our science fiction it is
going to be a watershed moment
and no it hasn't happened yet although
we don't have
a good definition of what consciousness
even is so
depending on how you would define it
maybe we have achieved that if you have
a very low bar
um i actually love to
compare this though to our history of
animal rights and our history of
not really caring that animals are
conscious in western society
because when you look at how we've
treated
other non-humans that have achieved
consciousness
arguably we haven't really
protected them or done anything about
that has not really been a watershed
moment
um the watershed moments have been more
about the animals that we find very cute
or that we relate to in some way
emotionally
pomeranians yes pomeranians
just as an example just i just pulled
that out i don't know why i said that
yeah we might we might think that we
care that the pomeranian is conscious
when really
we care that it is a cute little fluff
ball those are the fluffy ones that look
like balls right they are
yes yes yes but we haven't really
it hasn't been a watershed moment in the
animal kingdom so why would it be for
robots
um can i okay so the thing that's really
popular in movies is that the robots
become self-aware and they want to
destroy us
is it possible that the robots become
self-aware and it turns out
they're super delightful and we just
want to do like brunch with them all the
time
you know what i mean like why do we
always assume the evil part
you know um the guy i forget his name
the guy who
who runs pin board he's like an
entrepreneur guy
he uh has said that what if when the
robots become self-aware
um they are just crippled by existential
angst
and they just sit around all day
worrying about
artificial super super super
intelligence
like just because someone's smart
doesn't mean that they're not going to
be
like depressed what if they become drug
addicts
because they can't handle the reality of
you you don't know it's not it's not
what it is
what drugs extra usb cords i know that's
what i'm trying to figure out
i need some more usbc
i need that 5g
more bandwidth
[Laughter]
so that's an interesting point kate i
mean i i i don't want to
um under sell the point that you're
making here that
there's a lot to be gleaned by studying
our
prior relationship with animals there's
a lot of insights to come to that and
when
and not enough of us are are
are taking advantage of that those
lessons
and if we read your book then we will
know how to
yes i think that it's a it's an analogy
that works very well that we're all
familiar with
and yet we somehow always are comparing
robots to us
instead of to the other non-humans that
are autonomous that we've dealt with
previously
you know we had as a guest on star talk
the actor who played c-3po
in star wars and he said he's the only
person
in the world who knows what it's like
to be a robot
you're an actor you played a robot so no
no he's there in the robot outfit
and other people humans
are talking to each other completely
ignoring him until the moment they need
him to do something for them
and so this is the robot servant right
not the autonomous robot
and so he felt very lonely i don't want
to put words in his mouth but he was
describing this
feeling where he's only relevant when
they deem it
so otherwise he's just there
and that's a weird psychological state
that i wonder
we might need robots psychologists at
some point
i don't know isn't that just called
being an actor on set like
do you have to be wearing the robot
costume for that to happen
that is true but yeah because when
you're not needed no one
needs you right as an actor yeah they're
always telling you what to do
it's also like being everyone's little
sister right like isn't it just like
being a sibling
the younger sibling yes yes exactly the
younger sibling nobody wants you around
until they want you around i need you
right
so negan give me some more these are
good all right so from
lorenzo and elizabeth we have the
question do you think that we will ever
create an artificial intelligence
complex as much as our brain with
emotions
controlled by electricity that mimics
our biological
hormones and are we going to have a
digital conscious mind that can think
for itself
wow that's a that's a lot of questions
at once actually
um well let's unpack it so yes look at
this about uploading your consciousness
and then it's in a jar
and it's electronics so it's living a
whole life in a jar
like the matrix i mean look i
i think and i think i can answer all of
these questions the same way which is
it's really hard to make predictions and
i never say never right a lot of these
things
could happen uh or something that no one
has anticipated
could happen as we you know keep playing
with these technologies
um i'm less interested in like uploading
my consciousness to a jar than
some people are and more interested in
how we're gonna
deal with robots as entities
in our lives um but yeah i
i would not say no to any of those
things
uh but what do you think neil what
what are your predictions i strongly a
align with so much of where you're
coming from
among them is just because it's
something that may be even possible
is is anyone really going to want to do
that and i know do we people talk the
talk
but what are you accomplishing by that
and of all the advances as they come
over
is that going to be your highest
priority or is it going to be i wanted
to make a better cup of coffee i want to
get to detroit faster or i want to
you know there are other things that
might just simply have higher priority
in our lives
and that's how i kind of think about it
and
the science fiction writer bypasses all
the natural
needs and desires and priorities we
might have and goes to an extreme one
we're all going to die
and then they sell movie tickets i think
that's really what's driving it
but also like the idea that biological
hormones
would be replicated somehow in robots
i just want to say like i hope we don't
give them like
you know menstrual cycles like we don't
need to have
another race of thing be set by
menstrual cycles
like we done we did it i don't know how
to comment on that
but what i do know is that since
men have been in charge for most of
civilization it was they
who got to say how hormones are
affecting women
and whereas if women were in charge they
would have gotten to say
men you're messing up the world with
your testosterone
stop fighting put the weapons down and
so
we don't have a self-awareness of it
because like because we're just the guys
right
and but the world is so messed up
because of testosterone
and by the way i can say as a guy i i
feel it i mean i don't know
you know you're you know there's the
person
i mean how here's the here's a question
and is this duplicatable
in robots i guess is the ultimate
question here
is the rage a man
feels feels when someone cuts them off
at the red light or something or
whatever right
the number of men putting their head out
the window screaming
is incalculably higher than the number
of women who are reacting to that same
incident
uh the same way and why not just say
guys put down your
your hormones your your you're being
hormonally influenced
and but the men are in charge so we
don't get
to say that well you know some people
have even said that this idea that
artificial superintelligence would want
to kill us all is a straight-up project
projection of this male dominance
that is you know in in
[Laughter]
in our society and not anything that we
would build into machines
so that's interesting yeah so it's
because
like you said earlier there's a bias
you're going to put in whether you even
are self-aware of it or not and so here
are
all the science fiction stories and all
the the the horror stories and the
apocalyptic stories
and they're all having the robots behave
as men would
but in fact they're just robots yes
we do a lot of projecting of human
qualities onto
these machines and we could build them
that way and we might if we don't stop
to think about it but we don't have to
they don't even have to have gender yeah
and also i i just want to make a case
for like
projecting onto robots pomeranian
qualities
without what you will okay darling
that's what i'm pitching
so kate are you guys working on any
fuzzy cuddly robots
black robots those actually exist
um i wouldn't want to try to completely
replicate your pomeranian because
we could never get that right but any
any
robot that looks kind of like something
that people are familiar with but isn't
quite like it doesn't have to be a dog
but it could be like a baby harp seal
that one exists there's a baby harpsil
robot that's very cuddly
all right so we're already there okay
yeah yeah time for just a few more
questions
uh so we have from abby sheikh mature
um i would love to hear dr darling's
thoughts on artificial general
intelligence agi and its future
are there any other minds working on agi
other than dr ben gortzel
how promising do you think this approach
is
towards achieving strong ai yeah so
first tell us
what general the agi is
well right now um basically all
anything that people are working on in
artificial intelligence is very
narrowly focused so machines can do
a task or a thing within a
very narrow limitations but the ideal
that
some people are chasing is artificial
general intelligence which is something
that's more like human intelligence
humans are able to do a lot of different
things like
i'm talking to you here right now but if
if
one of these plants burst into flames
behind me i would be able to
leap out of my chair and do something
about it because i
have that contextual awareness and i can
task switch and i can do a lot of
different things and
and i'm flexible um but what the
machines that we've created so far are
not able to do that
at all and so some people are chasing
this goal
of trying to create more general
intelligence and machines unfortunately
we have no
clue how that can even happen
we don't even fully understand how human
intelligence works
so it's very difficult to create create
machines that can do that
and there's a couple different camps of
people
uh some people believe that that will be
possible soon uh
many people that i work with don't
believe that that's gonna be possible
or at the very least it's gonna require
so many smaller breakthroughs
before we even get close to it that um
we'll have a much better prediction of
what that would even look like
because that also we don't know what it
would even look like
could it be so that you will never
achieve
general agi you know artificial general
intelligence because
you will always have a targeted
ai that will do its task better than any
agi could possibly do it
that almost has to be the case i mean
you know
you know me i always say why are we
trying to recreate
agi when humans can do it why don't we
create something that's more useful that
can do something that humans can't do
we have great agi already okay i like
that
i like that this is this is the first
the most horrible whatever
you're very pro-human a pro-human uh
robot
expert yes yes this is i feel i'm
feeling better
thank you this has been yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so i time for like one maybe two
more questions
alec asks if you believe the brain is
nothing more than the sum of its parts
is it fair to say we can one day
recreate not just artificial
intelligence but artificial
consciousness so that kind of goes back
to the
becoming self-aware thing like is it
even in the cards technologically right
now
and or can you make a circuit that's
sufficiently complex
there's been a lot of assumptions that
if it is sufficiently complex
it is a natural next step through to
achieve consciousness
whatever that is and is that is that a
fair
uh guess i mean yeah we would need to
define
consciousness first in order to answer
that question
uh but i i do i
am very much in camp yes um this
we are just a sum of all of our parts
and in theory you should be able to
replicate the parts that we have we just
have no idea how to do that right now
there are things that come together and
become more than the sum of the parts
right
like you can analyze a bird in great
detail
and have and nowhere in there will you
have an understanding that
a group of birds will flock together
right that's a good point right so
that's an emergent
phenomenon that in fact only exists
in the group because one bird cannot
flock right that makes no sense so how
we've defined the word
so that so um just people have wondered
whether
consciousness is an emergent feature
that wasn't built in from the beginning
but sort of
shows up as a natural
consequence of the evolution of neuro
complexity
yeah that uh i mean that makes sense to
me but again it depends on how we define
consciousness right
right right and you know how you know my
best evidence for why i know we don't
understand
consciousness what best evidence you're
ready people
continue to write books about it
right so if you go to the shelf in the
library and say where are the physics
books
it's like this wide on the shelf it's
got like the newton physics the
einstein and that's it right so where
the books on the conscious and the mind
and the country it's
shelf after shelf after shelf and so
i think if we really understood it we
wouldn't have to keep writing books on
it
that's my measure we don't understand it
but we
really want to we are we really thank
you
but it's funny because i feel like you
know i
was obsessed with it too like i like all
those books were like people who were in
high school you know what i mean it's
like i
i questioned consciousness in in high
school and college and then i was just
like i'm good i'll ignore this question
i'll ignore this life's great question
who cares you know what i mean
so in high school i didn't you were
contemplating your consciousness in high
school that's cool
like yeah i feel like i went through
that fit right i was also goth
you know and i also went through like a
punk gypsy phase you know there was a
lot going on with me
um but i i feel like i
i i came to terms with like i can't
answer this question so i will move on
forever so
you were punk goth iranian
america this is all of this okay
yeah neil i don't even want to get into
i did mime for a while but i did not
no this is the last time no that's it
is that the last time i'm on their show
we have a mime rule here
neil is creating a very convincing box
for people who are
listening to the podcast they don't see
this i can't speak because i'm miming a
box
right hey so i think we got to call it
quits there but uh but kate it's great
to have you back on the show
and you have to promise us that when you
do
create a robot that achieves
consciousness you call us first okay
yes or a robot that can mine
[Laughter]
so again it's been great to have you we
love this topic it should be obvious
kate
and you know we're going to find you
again and
uh delighted and we just just learned
you're a new mom uh
for the second time that's great
congratulations thank you
and uh thanks again negine and kate
mcgain we can find her on on adult swim
at bird brain what's it called bird bird
girl bird girl
bird girl and your character really
scares me getting inside people's heads
and changing their mind
uh that's scary uh i have to catch a few
episodes and get back to you on that
and kate keep it up keep it going there
up at mit um we all love the media lab
such really cool things come out of
there and your work is no exception
to that so um everyone check out kate's
book
and give me the full title so i don't
mangle it it's the new breed
what our history with animals reveals
about our future with robots
and there's a lot of insights there that
i think can benefit us all
so that every time i have this podcast i
don't have to say we're all going to die
so thank you thank you kate for saving
us from that fate
thank you that's all we have time for
i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist